schicken da wirklich strom durch ich
glaube ja erwarte das wird so gefährdet
das leben auf dieser welt ist manchmal
nicht ganz einfach man geht in die
schule man geht zur arbeit man geht
vielleicht in die uni studiert und es
kann sich also immer anstrengend werden
und man braucht ein bisschen entspannen
und genau das werden wir heute wo leute
und ihr dürft dabei sein denn wissen
heute in das upgrade oddset ist fein
unterwegs da gibt es videos die extrem
zufriedenstellend sind und wir schauen
sollte diese videos an und schauen
einfach was macht die lustigen und
meinen lieblings kommentar unter dem
letzten video über die bkw hat server
wts geschrieben omg da ist der game
master omg bruder muss großbritannien
bei dem kommentar mit leute und wenn ihr
auch mal wieder vorbei an kommentiert
aber fleißig denke ich und was aus und
dann kommt vielleicht aufs video okay
aber es werde für das erste video bereit
das erst habe ich schon gesehen mal
gucken was du sagst synthetisches
polymer mit super wasser absorbieren
fähigkeiten
das ist so anders war hatte das kenn ich
das kino ja wie geil ist das ist hammer
aber ich kenne das aus einer late night
talkshow jimmy kimmel oder so und da das
so ein wissenschaftler demonstriert weil
durch polymer das in windeln baby
windeln um halt diverse flüssigkeiten zu
binden damit nicht auslaufen muss los
wurde also nichts wenn wir zwei spieler
stehen im exakt gleich moment auf zur
exakt gleichen zeit verkehrt das ist wie
bei prof
das ist wie bei kiefer genau wie so eine
animation am 1
für zwei spielcharaktere und dann machen
die genau das gleich ob vidal so ist der
seite der jäger zum laminieren oder
sowas haben wir auch mal gehabt mir
weißt dann werde ich nicht leiste über
alles laminierte ja in welche richtung
es geht
[Musik]
aber es ist nicht krumm ist da komme aus
oder so sagt man abziehen ist immer ein
eis bekämpft wenn man so eine bildschirm
folie hat auch so einen neuen kanal
es ist ja richtig geisteskrank
aber das hab ich heut scho wissen durch
gebrauch service nur zu sagen das ist
halt das geht halt auch nicht das halt
nicht möglich menschlich das ja das ist
natürlich für mich weil sowas so
unmöglich gewesen im kunstunterricht
das gibt es kann der fall ist kraft ist
auch dass das ist echt heftig dass die
fahrer so gleichmäßig bislang sieht aus
wie wiso einfüllt photoshop auch wie die
stiftung über das papier bewegt das ist
das ist da nicht manchmal passieren aber
auch dinge denen die begriffe war und
gelogen nicht gerecht werden wir nicht
dass menschen so etwas können auf der
welt bei mir weil es viel steht schon
mal dem ersten blatt einfach drüber
gegangen
er macht sogar ungewiss ist da wirklich
jemand so rahmen genommen habe geboren
alter sich somit um den welthunger
kümmern oder irgendwas ist dass die ja
die gab es dann noch so synchron fahren
dann hat das
what the [ __ ] wir fahren ja mal das
gefühl dass da nicht schlecht dabei wenn
man sowas sieht sogar eine
meisterschaftsfeier andererseits kann
man gibt ihm an wie schnell er das ding
das also dass wir wieder perfekt steht
das zu heften oder wirklich für mich da
nicht so was ich einfach schlecht ich
bin so körper klaus kennen sie das wenn
du denkst und dext ist also richtig was
du nicht gut gemacht hat wird gefilmt
dabei und es sieht einfach aus ist das
kenne ich jetzt nicht so läuft das bei
dir die galaxis sind holz mit gold rauch
malen so nein das wird herausgefräst das
feld hinter europa ist auch mal ich habe
erfolg von solchen videos man in supreme
entdecken
ich kriege so viel ist er ist dass wir
im slum größtes ist bekommt auf solche
ideen erwarten wir nicht funktioniert
das denn also klar ist ein spielzeug
autos aber die sind sind hier aufgezogen
nehme kaum nein das sind ferngesteuerte
autos nein die haben seien hier vorne
dran aber in die seile geht nicht
kommentieren
danach dabei komisch sind ferngesteuerte
autos man weiß es nicht
das kenne ich zum beispiel in riga
kranke was sie für sachen kennst du
zahlst noch krasser ist so plastikkarten
irgendwie fans sind wahrscheinlich in
einem privaten haus- und muss man sich
mal geben egal wie groß das alles ist
das geht doch weiter
ich dachte es qualität das finale ist am
besten
ich dachte dass wenn nur der erste alter
mann als jackpot dieses nina ist das
finale klar wir uns jetzt so von innen
nach außen sich sogar 3d ohne wirklich
wie man diese menschen treffen die so
was machen im leben was sind das für
menschen die größte aufwand das ist
sowas zu bauen also ganz kurz ich habe
gerade ganz kurzen flashback domino day
ist weil es noch dunkel oder das was sie
konnte ich hoffe kennt domino oder krank
kenne ich ach könnte sein dass du ganz
andere sache bekommt sowieso nicht so
eine spitze ist dann dass wir das so
flach abreißen und dann kommt so in
diese schokolade der adresse als
sechster des westens extra kollwitz
nicht richtig gänsehaut davon keine
chance gibt es gibt irgendwo ein wort
dafür wenn man einfach nur so an
satisfied videos interessiert dass sie
sexuell und ich habe menschen muss das
jetzt schicken natürlich strom durch ich
glaube dann erwarte das wird so
gefährdet
wie funktioniert das wohl einig dass in
dieser von der salzlösung die den
stromleitungen dann sind der
farbpartikel drin wenn diese
metallischen sachen geladen werden wird
das irgendwie angezogen und das ohne
frage gehört nicht nur ausfall gut ich
bin raus ich hatte das gar nicht die
coverstory ist das alter ohne wird sich
heute nur das ist so safe schwarze magie
c ich hätte niemals gedacht dass mich
das so krass mitnimmt ich habe echt
schon auf dem video zu sehen ich glaube
dass wir einfach nur bullshit alles klar
janáceks kuscheltiere gegen zucker wie
gesagt heute kommentiert fleißig um im
nächsten europe.com zu werden und auch
mit meinen kanal für mehr videos bis zum
nächsten mal max ist nämlich jetzt muss
ich ja was soll ich habe mal drei macht
es gut und liter leben